[Music]
marvel never disappoints when it comes
to cameos and surprise reveals and the
latest could change thor's story forever
in fact the mid-credits scene and thor
love and thunder may have teased a major
battle warning spoilers ahead the thor
movies have always tried to find the
humanity in omnipotent gods thor odin's
son may be worshipped across the lands
but at the end of the day he's really
just looking for acceptance and love
from those he holds dear nowhere is that
more evident than in his latest
excursion thor love and thunder the
stories of tony stark and steve rogers
may have closed their final chapters but
thor's saga is still being written in
between battling aliens and getting into
verbal spars with the guardians of the
galaxy thor's really just looking for a
new purpose you see things didn't
exactly end well between him and his
former flame jane foster sorry to hear
that jane dumped you
she didn't dump me you know
i dumped her mutual dumping
when she comes back into his life things
get complicated quickly they'll work
together to bring down gore the god
butcher and in the process thor may just
realize that it's better to love those
close to you for the short time you'll
be together than to go through a mortal
life alone that said where one battle
ends another seems just to be beginning
throughout his latest adventure thor
gets into some trouble in omnipotent
city when he strikes down zoos at first
it seems like the greek god is dead but
as we see in the mid-credits scene he's
still very much among the living and he
has some substantial plans to get back
at thor by sending one of his own after
him it seems obvious that it would take
quite a bit more than a lightning bolt
through the chest to take down a god
especially one so adept at wielding his
own electrical powers and as the tag
reveals he's still around surrounded by
his mistresses the scene starts with
this tableau featuring zeus speaking to
someone else off screen and it's clear
he holds a mighty big grudge against the
god of thunder toward the end of his
speech zeus makes it clear that he wants
an unseen warrior to take thor down a
peg it's at this point that we finally
get a look at who's on the other side of
this conversation
it's revealed that hercules played by
ted lasso star brett goldstein is now in
the marvel cinematic universe he looks
determined to make his father proud it's
at this point the screen cuts to black
and the rest of the credits roll it
doesn't give away much but it does imply
that hercules will get into a
confrontation with thor down the road it
wouldn't be out of the question for this
to transpire in a possible thor 5
especially seeing how the very end of
the credits promises that thor will
return it seems as though his trip to
omnipotent city will have wide-ranging
consequences when it comes to getting on
the wrong side of the greek pantheon
naturally hercules in marvel comics is
based on the hero from greek mythology
with a few noteworthy twists he's been
around in the comics for a while through
various iterations but his formal
introduction to mass audiences came in
the 1960s when he was introduced as a
rival to thor from that point forward he
became a regular fixture in thor comics
occasionally being a thorn in thor's
side but also being an ally given his
introduction in thor love and thunder it
would make the most amount of sense for
him to follow a similar trajectory in
the mcu it's possible hercules will
initially function as a rival but the
two will likely become friends over time
and team up to fight a much larger
threat and from there the sky's the
limit with the character in the comics
hercules went on to join the avengers
that team may be in a state of flux at
the moment but it'll inevitably reunite
and hercules could certainly factor into
that equation hercules has a long
history from the comics to pull from so
it's unlikely this will be the last time
we see him on screen as a part of the
marvel cinematic universe check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about sore love
and thunder are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]